press the wrong button and this robot
could destroy all these new chainsaws
to avoid just this scenario these
apprentices at the steel factory in
virginia beach are receiving four years
of occasional training
i like working with my hands
i like making things and when i found
out what the apprenticeship did
i thought
this is a good place for me to get
advancement within steel so i applied
for it and luckily i was one of the few
[ __ ] to get in
under the tuition of training director
thomas kuhner the students will learn
mechatronics the profession is well
established in germany and integrates
the disciplines of mechanical
engineering electronics and computer
programming
it's difficult to find qualified
trainees
often anyone with some technical
know-how is accepted into the program
they're usually in their late 30s and
with a military background
but such jobs are frequently looked down
upon in the u.s where they're considered
blue collar work
unfortunately 30 or 40 years ago the
trend was moving away from blue collar
jobs towards a college education
now people realize we don't have enough
skilled workers
you need this combination of theory and
practice that you only get in the dual
training system in europe or in germany
the vocational training takes place four
times a week in the evenings after work
will gross used to work in the factory
line with his new skills he hopes to be
able to do more
well
since i had been trying to study towards
that field of degree i
kind of knew i was going to be getting
into some involvement but not this
not this level of
complication it is
really different from
steel's annual turnover in virginia
beach is some 760 million euros
its customers are willing to spend a bit
more for the company's products because
quality is important to them and that's
why the vocational training program will
quickly end up paying for itself